on a une belle histoire pour vous ce
soir les serres lacoste cultive des
légumes de serre à saint-hubert depuis
plus de 35 ans avec nous ils vont
lacoste cofondateur des serres lacoste
et ismaël j'ai mille âmes les présidents
des entreprises lacoste bonsoir
messieurs bonjour monsieur lacoste les
terres sur lesquelles vous avez
développé vos terres appartenaient si je
me trompe pas votre grand père vous avez
pris la relève en 1985 et l'an passé
vous aviez décidé de vendre
racontez-nous comment vous avez
rencontré l'homme qui est à côté de vous
la la famille aml et bah écoutez c'est
est je pense un pur et adam ces
personnes ne se cherche et intérêts pour
cultiver
moi j'étais avant d y ont passé de
saint-amand sur le chemin ici ont vu la
garde à la façon que ces terrains
étaient installés ils se sont arrêtés on
ne visite et puis sept mois avec la
famille j'ai senti penser le coup puis
ça s'est fait de même voyons acheter là
ouais on a formé là on négocie on ne
forme une compagnie rejet - j'ai gardé
des ors d'un compagnies qui ont aussi
mis à travailler moi je travaillais
comme en proposent au hockey je je le
donne les actus et accumulé dans ma vie
eastwood et aux autres la famille qui
est passé c'est monsieur amené quitte à
côté de vous vous êtes d'origine
palestinienne
et là vous êtes arrivé au pays avec
votre famille en 1992 à vancouver et si
je me trompe pas vous étiez et vous êtes
toujours dix huit enfants dans votre
famille il y en a six qui sont impliqués
dans la ferme c'est ça cet exode de
rigolade
alors d'où vient votre intérêt pour
l'agriculture et pour la terre de
monsieur lacoste nous autres depuis
c'est dans la famille l'agriculture
présentement les gens sont dans
l'agriculture y font pousser des dates
des bananes
à deir ezzor puis c'est simple quand on
sait depuis qu'on est toujours en cours
et dans la griffe et de surplus mon père
en 1992 quand on a acheté une ferme mon
père je te faire mon à lons l'exploiter
pendant quatre ans 410 venue à montréal
ça a changé un peu le domaine puis après
15 ans je reste dans de s'imposer dans
la grippe est là on est loin quand même
des dates et des bananes qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous cultivez dans vos
sert présentement au cultive des
concombres centraux sans pesticides ont
fait des fines herbes et toutes des
transplants de données que les lieux et
brocolis toutes sortes d'énigmes et vous
monsieur la cause donc vous transmettez
savoir dans une nouvelle structure
d'entreprise avec monsieur amené exact à
maison dont dans une remise à niveau
on sent rouvert un niveau beaucoup plus
haut on a des projets de construction
qui sont assez importants savons très
bien qu'est ce qu'on fait et bien fait
bien apprécié par la population parce
que nos ventes sont très bons dans les
tuteurs ville fait que on peut de lui
puis ça se fait à mesure et on on
croyait que le chemin qu'on prince est
bon et monsieur a laissé coi
l'importance d'avoir monsieur l'acoss
toujours avec vous impliquer dans
l'entreprise et monsieur lacoste juste
ton expérience de ces lacoste une
expérience que de 45 ans que ça s'achète
pas et puis moi je me sens forte unie
d'un bon monsieur lacasse est que nous
autres parce que qu'est ce qu'on apprend
de monsieur lacoste même dans les écoles
même qui tu t'en vas y tu dis tu
apprendras jamais les secrets que lui a
développé au rang d'icône des années qui
apparaît dans l'agriculture que les
sacres avec tes légumes car si c'est un
don de dieu qu'on travaille et vous êtes
ses frères ses sa a travaillé aux serres
lacoste
oui on espère un contrat ben salah costa
va tout ensemble puis oui on y c'est la
famille donc vous manquez pas de mes
deux si je comprends bien oui on en haut
manga maîtrise est difficile de recruter
la main est présentement à cause de la
crise premièrement oui parce que là
c'est chez eux que les personnes des
personnes qui travaillent ont peur
d'attraper des maladies à cause de ça
mais on prend les précautions on fait
attention dit ce que beaucoup avec les
personnes tournent en gage mais on eu
réellement les airs à recruter mais est
ce que est ce que c'était comme ça avant
dans les dernières années où là en ce
moment il ya un véritable enjeu qui vous
touche
il ya un certain enjeu de toute façon
deux autres on est décidé moi je suis
enseignant de profession on est on est
en train d'établir un programme de
formation pour nouveaux employés enfin
qu' on va tout faire pour elle-même
l'entreprise table puis un maillage et
surtout du personnel qui qui fait quoi
ouais efficacement et on voit l'écart à
de l'information puis enfin travailler
monde ici dans d'autres entreprises
c'est notre but c'est le but c'est
d'être à 100%
cela dit beaucoup de travailleurs
étrangers sur les terres partout au
québec qui sont absolument nécessaires
pour l'agriculture présentement oui dans
certains corps d'une zone qu'est ce
qu'on veut faire c'est de réellement
donner la chance aux québécois de 2,5
écrit au niveau où j'ai eu dix ans dans
la province ici on va engager la montre
de notre ville on va engager le mot
disons le cadre exactement comment vous
voyez l'avenir de l'agriculture au
québec monsieur a mené et qui sait c'est
très très très très difficile
l'agriculture au québec on va pas se
cacher avec les compétitions coc note
avec tout les produits qui viennent mais
qui existent unis que sur les prix du
marché du monde la can take si c'est
très très difficile mais nous qu'est ce
qu'on essaie d'abord on essaie de daran
sol
le maximum qu'on peut leur rentabiliser
notre business puis essayer de faire un
succès avec monsieur lacoste en termine
à l'avenir des serres lacoste est entre
bonnes mains avec monsieur amené witt
entre très bonnes mains parce que c'est
des gens qui sont travaillants c'est des
gens qui apprennent très vite
don du carreau un puits que moi et et je
t'avais que haut depuis un an et demi
depuis vendu puis je trouve que c'est un
très bonne famille qui veulent apprendre
ils sont solidaires puis je crois que si
les qualités requises pour faire un bon
un bon team une bonne équipe pour est
capable de réagir premier contact
alors merci bonne chance pour la suite
bon ben merci beaucoup monsieur la
prochaine